notre envoyé spécialà chez miche à la
frontière ukraino polonaise bonjour à
vous tarek tarek caille vous êtes arrivé
il ya deux jours à la frontière où
l'afflux de réfugiés se poursuit chez
miche est donc l'une des toutes
premières villes de l'union européenne
qu'atteignent ceux qui fuient le conflit
qu'observée vous sur le terrain
tout à fait chez michelin qui se trouve
à l'est de la pologne une ville de 60000
habitants et comme vous l'avez dit c'est
la première ville de l'union européenne
et c'est là où l'afflux des réfugiés se
sent le plus dans ce long périple
qu'entreprennent tous ceux qui fuient la
guerre nous sommes arrivés à apcher
michel vers 3 heures du matin et nous
sommes allés directement à la gare
centrale où venait d'arriver justement
un train qui entrait en gare qui venait
d'ukraine et notamment de lviv à bord de
ce train des centaines de personnes donc
qu'ils fuyaient le conflit ce qui était
frappant de voir c'était cette activité
qui étaient là trois heures à 4 heures à
5 heures à 6 heures du matin ce que nous
avons vu également c'est donc justement
beaucoup d'ukrainiens qui venait mais
aussi il y avait beaucoup de
ressortissants étrangers il y avait
beaucoup de gens qui dormaient par terre
des enfants des femmes mais également
beaucoup de jeunes personnes nous avons
vu donc beaucoup de criminels comme je
le disais mais beaucoup d'étrangers donc
d'aider cameroun et des soudanais des
irakiens des syriens qui fuyait tous la
gare ils nous ont tous parlé des
conditions extrêmement difficiles qu'ils
ont connue lors de cette traversée de
l'ukraine certains venaient d'odessa
d'autres de lviv dugain d'autres de kiev
ou même donc d'euractiv ils nous ont
parlé des conditions extrêmement
difficiles du froid glacial des des
nuits qu'ils ont passées dehors sans
abri de ses dizaines de kilomètres
qu'ils ont traversé à pied dans le but
de traverser cette frontière il ya aussi
cesser ces histoires extrêmement
touchante de ces personnes qui ont connu
déjà des dames dans la vie ces personnes
comme je le disais donc qu'il soit
ukrainiens ou même ressortissants
étrangers qu'ils soient irakiens ou
soudanais ou même si rien je pense
notamment à ce chef cuisiner irakien qui
avait connu la guerre en irak qui avait
fui d'âge qui s'était réfugié au liban
qui a connu l'explosion du port de
beyrouth et qui retrouve la guerre
justement avec les bombardements et
c'est à ce drame ce nouveau drame qui
vient se rajouter justement à son
parcours merci beaucoup tarek vous étiez
en direct donc de cette frontière situé
à la pologne on va prendre maintenant la
direction de kiev où